c'est devenu un symbole de résilience un
emblème qui s'est multiplié dans les
foyers des québécois mais avant de se
répandre ici c'est en italie qu'il a
fait sa marque
j'ai repris la phrase rendra tout
aubaine et puis je les traduis
en français gabriella cuccinelli est une
québécoise d'adoption c'est elle
l'instigatrice du mouvement ça va bien
aller au québec
elle avait remarqué l'élan de solidarité
dans les journaux italiens qu'elles
consultent régulièrement quand j'ai vu
ça j'ai pour moi c'était comme si
j'avais trouvé le moyen d'extérioriser
on peut l'anxiété l'impuissance que je
vivais en ce moment là et j'ai trouvé
quand même que c'était une image et
présente plein de couleurs et avec des
mots rassurante et première mesure
venait d'être annoncé par le
gouvernement le goût lorsque gabriel
l'accoutumée lee et ses enfants ont
dessiné leur premier arc en ciel et
c'est là que le mouvement a réellement
pris de l'ampleur
j'ai voulu créer d'autres enfants
puissent prendre du plaisir à faire
cette activité là avec des mamans avec
leurs proches et de pouvoir afficher ce
message à leurs fenêtres
j'ai les partager dans une page facebook
qui regroupe 26 mille personnes qui
travaillaient avec la petite enfance
aujourd'hui rares et celui qui ne
connaît pas le mot clic ça va bien aller
sur les réseaux sociaux ou celui qui n'a
jamais aperçu les couleurs de l'arc en
ciel aux abords d'une fenêtre
plusieurs monuments au québec et dans
certains villes de québec sont illuminés
allard couleurs de l'arc en ciel
c'est je trouve ça vraiment beau puis si
ça peut venir soulager les gens de ces
moments de crise bay et c'est tant mieux
gabriella cuccinelli veut maintenant
protéger la marque
non pas pour empocher des profits mais
pour aider les plus vulnérables
elle veut que les entreprises qui
utilisent l'arc en ciel aux côtés de
slogans ça va bien aller fassent un don
à l'organisme la cantine pour tous si ça
fait du bien et je suis content ici
m'arrêter à merci radio canada québec